Tiger King on Netflix I started its so
me episodes deeper I'm in the middle of
the second episode it's a documentary on
the sky in with the tiger sanctuary oh
oh he's a gay man really uh husband
llama two husbands what he's a tiger
himself first
well that guy's a man tiger it's he's
such a character and he's crazy the
country singer it he does music videos
good look up his music video chin his
name's Joe exotic well naturally it's
also a murder mystery because there's
this lady in PETA who's in Florida who's
trying to shut down his business and the
he like wants to put a hit out on her so
it becomes this whole ordeal
it's so dramatic all the other tiger
sanctuary people get involved it's so
fast what's the lady that he hates so he
hired this actress that looks like her
and talks about killing her
it's called here kitty kitty he's say
this not a terrible sing it no he can
sing pretty well my Chin's gonna hail
out but you expect it to be horrible
yeah he's from Oklahoma
she's trash that I'm down yeah
when they told me he's making music I
was gonna be terrible it what does she
want him to do with his cats no she
thinks it's a thinks it's inhumane she's
PETA so he has these Tigers but it was
300 almost to do with those Tigers if
you have 300 put him down somebody's
gotta take care of him right well but
he's using it for a financial benefit so
he's making him do [ __ ] he's he's
killing him he's doing yeah he's like
take you in the malls and he's taking
kittens and then they they're never in
the wild he just takes all these kittens
and raises them how much do you think
it's how your cos price not a lot
probably because there's so many of them
in captivity
there's life cap to is not many in the
world oh no I know that they're very
endangered but because of habitat I
don't much is a cost if I wanted to buy
one five grand
two grand yeah but here's where it gets
dicey them bad boys grow up you gotta
feed them so all the Tigers he had he
said you spend between two to three
hundred thousand dollars a month and
food in meat who's paying for it what do
you mean so yeah that's how he pays for
it he has people come and come to this
just shows yeah
why what does she expect him to do with
those Tigers well I don't know about
that I don't think she gives a [ __ ]
about you I think she wants to take care
of the Tigers she thinks he's you know
using miss Trina and being inhumane and
killing them
I say yeah you're not pitas is he
killing them he is killing the Tigers
why because you know these are certainly
a jury don't need him anymore so is he
having them is he putting allow for
canned hunts or something what no
because sometimes in Texas you put him
out on a ranch and you can pay to kill a
tiger a lion mm-hmm what's he doing
shoot them in the head right it's okay
shoot him in the head but Kay I don't
give too much out we're gonna wanna
watch it's the best I've met you on that
please go along it's really it's fast
and that's a Peter seven part series
Peter girl all right it takes so many
turns and these other guys get involved
and then his mentor's that like kind of
like the Crocodile Hunter of tigers and
he was like seven wives it's crazy he
ever heard so in the bond or some girl
gets armed [ __ ] bit off alright don't
show it don't tell me more they show her
AA video oh my god
so in bandar-log in the bounder logs
which is in India that's where Tigers
for whatever reason in that area attack
humans and there are a lot of theories
on why but there are fishermen who are
out in their canoes oh yeah and they're
fishing and the tiger will go huh hunts
them I'm gonna swim out in the water and
I'm gonna jump into your boat and pull
you into the water and then swim you
back on shore and eat you and I'm gonna
come back for your friend and that's
what happens there's a book there's a
book on this and they did a movie on it
too really yeah there's what there's a
guy who shot one of the Tigers like
there's like three Tigers shot one right
took em the Tigers ran off weeks later
one of those same Tigers the guys on the
river and it's hunting them the whole
time just hunting him I mean well nope
walking along whoa hunting them like
hiding where this is this is in part of
tiger King no no no yeah I'm talking
about your story yeah hiking there's no
time no hunting going on you need you
need you later sacrificing here's a
problem with a gun too apparently
that when you when you are like sitting
there protecting tiger you have to have
somebody watching your back because
they're so quiet they can [ __ ] take
you they'll attack you from behind and
they don't break a twig under their
[ __ ] five hundred pound body it's
crazy to me is this psyching uh right
obviously batshit crazy preying on them
you know how does he know how to handle
Tiger never bit never scarred nothing
shows him like wrestling with the Tigers
Tigers
he has Tigers Tigers just powder
leopards you know what that is powder
leather hey come on look at the size
that [ __ ] thing that's a Bengal tiger
is that I have Siberian look at the size
of it mm-hmm
goddamn that's a giant animal what you
learn is because they show like four or
five different big cat sanctuary you
realize they're all pretty [ __ ] up
right it's a dark world
yeah you said powder leopard stole on
I'm not powder cloud I might be cloud
now wait not a snow leopard cloud
Leopard yeah
they're loud about it Leopard yep yeah I
know what though get you some Wow
I [ __ ] hate cats in general I don't
like cats I think they're [ __ ] stupid
but you know to feature its own this and
I'm aware of them you know how much the
house cats would I be allergic to a
tiger I don't think so
do they shed man leopards are so amazing
though they are amazing animals their
speed their their stealth there are such
effective hunters there's small clouded
leopards huh cat huh dude was selling
these animals all over the place I guess
two for two two husbands gets married
two husbands one guy missing teeth don't
give a [ __ ]
why you did that's a good [ __ ] this
guy's tough to see ya like them kissing
like wrangling camel well some people
are just kind of bad huh but usually
like they say a lot of times if you're
really in the animals you probably don't
like people that much there's their who
they are so check this out homeboy on
the right
super gay guy in the middle is gay as a
gift guy in the left is 19 he's seen the
cat he's night it's early enough that
he's night raid [ __ ] must hey he gets
there
and he just wants to work with big
animals he's a straight man he's 19 he's
a straight guy in the car they're in the
car and exotic Joe goes how straight are
you and the guy he goes pretty straight
man I've never been with the dude he
does yeah let me ask this we watch porno
do you watch dude search for guys with
big dicks [ __ ] the girl or small dick
for his well big dicks he goes you need
that straight because I only got married
really well then they got married okay
so now here's the thing oh how did jump
I didn't go they started dating hey it
went
you didn't you ain't that gay boom
wedding see he's a he's a looker that
kid six six six six six it's Hey Dude
he's got some shoulders on him too by
the way yeah I I search for big dicks
too and I'm straight so you know I'm
saying so I'm not gonna marry Tiger can
I give a spoiler
okay you want to know kind of I wanna
know if you're gonna watched I can have
seen it stop listing in three two one
so homeboy who is like not that's not
that straight you know what happened to
him do you know what happened to him
Brian well cuz he was a straight man it
was like oh I won't play with Tiger
snakes you know he's getting [ __ ] in
the ass in the mouth oh you know what
happens to him a year later he blows his
[ __ ] brains out in front of a tiger -
alright - get that out oh we're back Wow
no Wow [ __ ] well you have to get that
out clearly he was clearly a lost sorry
clearly a lost young man yeah and by the
way was anybody there when he did it
could have been the Tiger king himself
you gotta watch my car Wow hate ya damn
it look at this he's got this eye brow
pierced he's every bit of my age oh dude
his mullet is just that the dye jobs
ridiculous outfit underneath
he runs manager and a peon transfer uh I
think governor or mayor of Oklahoma
office he loses he's on but the master
manipulator he's
show me yeah see those dogs that that
guys holdin you see those dogs down
there those are my favorite dogs you
know kind of dogs those are where these
trolleys Australian Shepherd got a
catalogue so I grew up with dude I you
did yeah look at me lovin man all right
well they're paying the ass right
because they need a job and they're
super hyper there so this is just dogs
they're cool they're fast athletic smart
writer with some of the smartest all
right
good with two huh grew up with two just
all right though all right dude you
think of a thousand other dogs I'd
rather have really that's his new man -
he's not an attractive man's well do but
when it dude apparently all they showing
up they have another gathering another
dude on their living seven why his
business plan was he gets young dudes oh
good good dude
so he gets these Tigers right this other
cat Wrangler puts him in a suitcase and
brings into Vegas then brings her like
strippers hotels and stuff then it shows
homeboy he's an open relationship
just [ __ ] all these strippers and
they're holding Cubs guys no no girls
hot girls because they want pictures
with these kittens these baby tigers so
he's like oh I got Tigers they [ __ ] all
the less the guest picture so that's the
bravest thing I've ever seen while dude
behind the backs like what the [ __ ] am i
doing I don't know man it's pretty
amazing the guy in the front I when you
see me like that really are you sure
you're gay yeah it looks like a tough
kind of tough cat looks like a bit of a
rapist you know I mean he's raping that
ass I mean you know I mean like just he
looks like like gay men who are macho
were like they a little scary you don't
like well I'm gonna take that I'm gonna
get in the bottom I hate when we take
this picture you get on your knees I'm
like no I'm gonna get you have Gery guys
knees these are the greatest pictures
I've ever seen in my life
you know look at this [ __ ] hanging out
the front those khakis yeah fat dick
spirit yeah well I was just busting nuts
that [ __ ] got some Tigers busting nuts
look this money turning to Tiger [ __ ]
monday didn't it look at that there you
go this is great that poor dude was not
gay
that guy is a [ __ ] character oh wait
you I got the Christ
thorn like way to watch it it did he's
such a madman
Joe exotic Joe exotic I don't tell what
he's doing now cuz I'm gonna spoil the
show more but he's such a character you
realize that they're all fuck-ups all
the big cat sanctuary guys are just
fuck-ups yeah and she hair she's [ __ ]
creepy they're all creepy dude
yeah he's probably over under bad guy
good guy in the middle complicated again
got a lot hate it complicated you gotta
watch it and you tell me what you think
all right
also I I don't know I don't I don't put
too much in the documentaries because
they have a narrative to paint you know
yes so and then I did some behind the
scenes research after and Netflix was
like we wanted to do a follow up on
where they are now they go but the way
we did the documentary we knew a lot of
the characters who we use are can attack
this once they see what we did something
oh [ __ ] okay that's that's a problem
right because people can change your
story pretty easily a little bit of a
bad guy I mean but the facts and you
know when you hear what they're doing
with some of these cats I got [ __ ]
you're not trying to help these cats out
yeah and you feel bad for the animals
man like just just in these [ __ ]
cages it's terrible
well Tiger should not be in cages yeah
that's all these [ __ ] Tigers are
there they live in cages that's all they
do not have a habitat like it's it's
it's like sighs this room they jump or
they they need to roam yeah I do
yeah well it's a bummer yeah I don't
know if there should be I don't you
shouldn't be breeding Tigers in a
sanctuary shouldn't be breeding Tigers
and and having them live their lives in
a cage and then and then it just you
know then they gotta make money so they
make money off selling them so then and
you know and there was an a law for ever
they passed some big cat law we're now
it's illegal to own them but I think as
of 2016 you could just own cats and it's
all good it's not a giant tire so what
what a parable idea terrible what you do
with it you have to have a certain
license I think but no you didn't know
know that this they passed the rule this
PETA lady helped out though yeah crazy
right it's like owning
chimpanzees - people would buy chimps
they'd be really cute this is in the
seventies in the eighties you have a
chimp like this is the greatest threat
of all time by [ __ ] everywhere but
he's also throwing things but also he's
sued eyebrows eight nice nine that he's
ten and he's an adolescent and his balls
are dropping and testosterone was
running through his body and his face it
used to be so white and cute is now
turning dark and ran his teeth are
getting [ __ ] huge and oh he ripped my
face off and my genitals off and he's
stronger than three men when when does
it chimp become like a man I think it's
eight or nine they become adolescents
and dangerous in that big in that Tiger
King doctor if they show a thing of
Tigers when they're good when you can
have them like do the shows and stuff
it's only like a couple months it's like
six months whether it shows here where
they're like in their prime yeah you
don't wanna know
chimpanzee begin watering short
distances from their mothers in about
eight months of age chimpanzees enter
adulthood about 13 years yeah that'd be
a good run with a chimp thirteen years
your buddy before he rips your dick
ecology here that one lady was [ __ ]
them having in a robe getting like Zane
oh yeah [ __ ] yeah and then one day is
like you know what dude face to see what
age of chimpanzees mature our ways of
chimpanzees become dangerous maybe well
fast my age of five are stronger than
most adults yeah become destructive and
resentful
they can't the [ __ ] wants to have a
chimp chimp tiger any of that [ __ ] what
are you doing dude I don't know people
want to be different you know it's so
weird
let's say people have snakes - what the
[ __ ] are you doing man what do you do
with that snake I don't know like
venomous snakes like cobras and [ __ ] let
me do it that [ __ ] thing can't
snuggle it tell you this right now yeah
yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
Oh [ __ ] business